coup de projecteur à présent sur le
quartier des deux lions à Tours un
ensemble sorti de terre dans les années
90 qui ne devait au départ accueillir
que des activités tertiaires sauf
qu'aujourd'hui de nombreux tours enjaux
ont choisi d'y vivre mais déplore le
manque de commerce de proximité 4
projets ont été retenus pour implanter
ces petits commerces entre la ligne de
tram et le centre commercial et vous
avez jusqu'à la fin du mois pour
désigner votre préférée Léa Turquie
ici dans quelques années devrait se
trouver trois kiosques pour enfin
accueillir des commerces de proximité
dans le quartier des deux lions lorsque
l'on demande ce qu'il manque ici aux
habitants les voix sont unanimes une
boulangerie principalement un petit un
petit magasin de Presse Café une genre
de petite brasserie un truc comme ça il
y a pas de boulangerie ou quand la seule
qui est dans le quartier là est fermée
on a plus grand chose
voilà pour le midi ça fait un petit peu
défaut je pense
qu'on est au moins des petits commerces
alimentaires de proximité et alors là ça
serait le Must a marché ça ce serait
vraiment chouette parce que celui qu'ils
avaient mis il y a quelques années ça
n'a pas tenu mais je pense qu'il y a
vraiment maintenant un réel besoin pas
de pain frais le matin ni de fleuriste
ou de tabac presse des lacunes soulevées
depuis 2013 par l'association Vivre les
deux lions alors l'installation de 4 à 5
commerces indépendants confèrent une
vague de soulagement c'est aussi le
sentiment d'être dans un qui vit dans un
quartier où les gens peuvent se croiser
dans des lieux qu'ils partagent avec
d'autres pour des intérêts puis communs
et puis se parler enfin voilà tout ce
qui se passe dans des petits commerces
indépendants un réel besoin ou deux
lions qui a bien changé au fil des
années pensez à l'origine comme un
technopole avec un centre commercial le
quartier regroupe maintenant 4000
habitants et plus de 6000 étudiants il
n'a pas été fait pour être un lieu de
commerce de proximité et c'est ce
travail là avec la pharmacie la poste et
maintenant c'est kiosque que l'on essaye
de développer c'est à dire comment faire
des deux lions un quartier j'ai presque
envie de dire banal ou l'on retrouve des
services des espaces verts des
équipements des commerces le sondage
consultatif concernant l'architecture
des kiosques est accessible en ligne
encore jusqu'au 30 janvier du côté des
commerces leur installation est pour
l'été 2025